each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
I can see in both of us right so I've
just flown over from Perth which is a
lot of steps away from here so it's
purposive need Sydney to la la de here
so apparently you guys have a 20-percent
to speed up on your video recording so
if you want to use that later that's
probably come so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to talk about the analysis
that we're doing on Electra beer events
and how what we're doing and improve
your ability to detect mutations in a
sequence when you ought some just
sequencing a regular sample from God so
you want to detect a mutant variation in
sequence or anus detriment that easy so
just a little bit about who we are where
we come from behind that his Perth in
Western Australia which looks a bit like
Stafford today would say shine another
view and the water probably rains a lot
here I've never seen it yet but people
citizen and the company is basically
formed by myself and and David say in
august 2002 we got completely
overwhelmed by the amount of work we
have to do so we have to endure as well
now is for completely overwhelmed but we
just better or boy what we wanted to do
with the company is we wanted to develop
a generic software that you could use
the sequencing-based genotyping and that
you could use in a clinical situation
and the other things we do our day
because molecular body consultancy and
he's got a lot of experience developing
essays using that DNA he's also a lot of
experience doing international course
insurance programs and so we can do that
and the company itself has a very strong
collaborative relationship with that
department of clinical immunology and
Roper and that's all the raw data comes
from
so david has been a sinner scientists at
royal birth for 12 years and he's been
doing sequencing as long as we do
sequencing so he's had a lot of
experience and he's also had a lot of
experience in developing mobile
strategies and he developed a lot of the
early multiplexing pcr type of a phase
where you would try and amplify
different alleles of a Virginian in one
question so he's got a lot of
propagations related for that and this
is me and my career that's been a little
bit varied and first I'll get laser
spectroscopy at Oxford and Arizona State
was obviously very similar places and
then crates that want the other just a
bit warm in Arizona and so I did
continues wave and pulsed laser
spectroscopy of sort of visible and UV
in those places then I went to Japan
another brace and reliability and did
microwave spectroscopy on mountain
weather is an observatory of alternative
radio telescope after that are here
again following the completely and
linear line of my career path went to
Singapore and get programming
consultancy for telecoms so I won't sync
up and then after that I mean to world
birth which was the next logical step
and the reason that I went to Robert
because my brother was working there as
a student and David when a student comes
in put that says in you know anything
about computing because we've got all
these electropherograms in huge amounts
of edible weed in a bit of a problem
analyzing more my brother said no I
don't really have a good you know if
that's my brother that yes
so roll purpose and been on since about
1829 which at which time was probably
just a couple of points in abortion and
from there it's progressed a little bit
and there are two sequences in their
clinical immunology lab 137 30 which is
the highest three-book machine from ABI
for sequencing the other one is if they
100 in a bit older that you can know
about 5,000 sequences of 508 and the
base pad per week for those the lab
itself does tissue typing so it tightens
people's immune systems and the only
method that the lab is currently leading
for that is sequencing so there are no
preliminary methods and no broad typing
methods the hospital also provides a
statewide DNA sequencing service so you
built in commercial sequencing for
people outside Hospital the quality of
data comes out of that and sequencing
lab means that our pH is one of them
want my father used during the
registries in the world that by Meryn
solid organ and because we have ties
with a lab we've got a good link to
novel a chelate studies and also a lot
of HIV sequence from a professor oil and
his subsequent
so this is some of the clinical
applications of DNA sequencing the first
one is tissue typing and that's where
we've come from though matching donors
and recipients for bone marrow and solid
organ the next one is viral genotyping
so this is the stuff that's being done
with HIV you try and think the part what
components and watch genotypes the
president an individual by something
directly HIV that's been instructed in
the lab work you can also do bacterial
fungal Guillen typing to identify
infections and that's already been done
in a clinical case you can get that
identification climb down to under 24
hours instead of leaks that it takes to
grow these things sometimes so that's a
fairly important clinical application
and DNA sequencing coming needs to
analyze only the poly point all the
credits a direct measure the sequence
it's the most comprehensive way to do
both types days you can also do an SMP
is using then in sequencing measure
agent costs and volumes go down that's
becoming more and more commercial so why
why use down in sequencing as opposed to
another method when you do measure down
in sequence you identify directly
sequence of places in that routine that
you're feelin there's no inferred dating
during the sample small part regarding
then infer what the less it is in
previous studies so if there's a noble
boy mazel polymorphism you always see it
you'll never miss that its quantitative
so you can measure the amount of the
secondary solutions or linton population
and that's quite a controversial because
most people who have done this
previously wouldn't have been able to
make it complicated
you'll also generate a complete data set
so if you're spending a particular area
of the gene and we later find out if
there's another layer by important area
if you've sequence there's a good chance
that you've got that data as well as
original deck so you can if you do a new
analysis you can probably pick up
without a little experiment also receive
dancing you can use a single platform
for looking at clothes looking at
singing cloud polymorphisms and you can
scroll those in populations and you can
do genotyping all-in-one platform this
land routine on a set of people so it's
going to be efficient this is what
happens in the lab kind of basic
overview you get a sound of all that
comes into the lab and blood or whatever
and you'll get the you know it's flat
the DNA from it in one experiment then
once you've got extract that you'll use
a PCR to amplify the DNA and then select
with biology that you're going to ask
them look at so once you've got your
amplifier product Avengers sequencing
reaction to label that so that it can be
measured using a generic sequencer you
gave asleep representing you collect
results so when you get the specimen you
need to record all information so
there's a lot of database management is
going to go into making a clinical of
successful you need to be able to manage
all your protocols and then you develop
the track the outcomes of each stage of
each reaction so that you need to make
sure that extraction is successful in
the eventual of the application is
successful you make sure that the
sequencing reaction was successful all
of these statuses be managed in one
place and there's currently no
commercial system available to do that
easily
you also need to be on a full analysis
of the lack of theorems and he didn't
pick consolidate the results and make
sure that what you get out is the same
for something other than the right
houses also if you want to only
additional study on that sequence that
way that your sequence w of ACP things
from there well argue is the second
thoughts that which is not as if it
depends on your queen on that that if
you have you clean up method of you
button up again a then it shouldn't be
noisy so if you're optimizing conditions
of work you should get quite specificity
so I don't hear the thing that you're
looking for nothing else and it should
get a good amount of that sort of the
signal-to-noise ratio is very hard to
get good simple tune up you're not going
to have too much of a problem with high
noise so let's go over what you gain
with sequencing this briefly so anybody
with a passport on video can possible
about the film about it so first thing
you do is you amplify the park then if
you want to look at so first thing is
you get your double stun and you heat it
up so that the test runs separate then
you get a little primer which is a set
of basis it fixes into the down a the
point you want to amplify and you put
those primers on fire cooling that
amidst it down a little bit so they only
binds the place you want to find them
and you add some extra bases using an
enzyme reaction and extend the change up
and get your own protection and if you
this have many times it takes to get a
good amount of DNA
so when you've got your DNA how do you
get it into a form we can measure that
symptoms of basis what you do is you you
do another amplification reaction but
instead of just using regular basis life
you also use some bases that are tangled
diet so each die is a different color
and into those different curves can be
picked up by a ccd camera inside the
machine so if i have a G in my sequence
a compliment of that is a seat and I'll
type out with a bleeder I and I'll put
down in on my sequence and so I'll know
that the seventh base in one sequence is
a C and you can go down or other and
I'll keep doing that until I know what
the basis of every position now the
number of each of those different round
fragments is highly dependent on the
rate of incorporation of the dye versus
the rate of incorporation of a regular
base so if I have a very good
incorporation make the dough and I'll
get a good strong signal for that
particular fragment length if I have a
bad incorporating rate that I'll get a
much weaker signal at a particular
position so what will happen is you know
electropherogram you'll get signal
strengths at a highly variable depending
on the sequences gone before
so when I get those fragments I put them
in my test you and I've I put in through
a capillary and the rate at which
they're drawn through the script only by
an electric electrical potential is poor
tional to the length of the
approximately proportional to the length
of F fragment so what I'll get is I'll
get the Saudis fragments coming off
first and there longer and longer
fragments are coming off and each of
those fragment has a label are told me
what their lust places so the first
pagnell I'll come up and that's got a
gene label so it will go through the
laser and the laser will say and will
sign on a lil Flores have the g
wavelength and the CCD I'll think it
I've decided this fragment has a jail
next one will come through that
threatens got mail yet that's one will
come through maybe there are two types
and no one's got a team on their neck so
that will give me a mixed base theater
for the next position and you can see in
this example that the hearts of these
pics are very buried so it's hard to say
in the case where there's two bases
which base comes from what substitution
and the variability also makes it more
difficult to distinguish between what's
real and what's not because essentially
if you look at that I've initio pecan
surrounded
so what you measure is a combination of
everything that went into that test you
in the pcr and the big range is dynamic
so when you measure a lot of sequences
you're getting these profiles that are
highly variable and the signal to noise
makes it difficult to pick out some of
that pepper virus positions you can see
that I mean this is a 50 nominally a
50-50 mixture and beans wondered there
on the left they're clearly not shaking
50-50 distribution of intensity in other
thing is when you measure a sequence you
can measure it in the forward direction
standing sequence or you can measure it
in reverse direction ascendancy and if
you both of those experiment design of
the profiles are different because when
you extending the reverse be binding on
two different span again ebony mixed and
cool so there's this variation between
for another season which is a help
because it's as noise in one won't be
like latinos nua because when you put
your hands on one for the span of DNA
going forwards behind that already
attached is a particular structure of
DNA if you put it on the other end as a
different structure of DNA so the
efficiency of binding at that that
different instruction will be different
so the rate of reaction will be
different on the others fan so the rate
of incorporation of dyes will be
different so the profile is it
so so I'm coming in from this side at
the actg you see a and a God's into the
side coming from this write-up dozen
typically different communities advisor
do you know it's actually from sin
because depending on what primers used
to start the sequencing reaction tells
of extracting again
these visual context it seems to be a
small context because if you make it so
something like HLA has like a 20-percent
variability of between sequences if you
look at five bases out from a
polymorphism you look at save got CNN or
an a you look firebase about an ecstasy
belt peanuts be the same intensity of
whether you've got the earth five paces
away so the context is peaceful
the must you must be able to analyze
those things and that you know what
these peak i tatti tell you is
structural information and instead of
trying to balance the pit pass out using
engineering McGann's on what you really
want to be doing is using that
information ask spectral information to
help you give you an answer no because
if it tells you the relationship between
two more point multi if you put so if
I've got two sequences around provide by
a different slightly different primers
they've got a point orphan in the prime
site if I've envio sequencing reaction
on the product from primal and primer to
five basic dandelions and have the same
profile so even with even with different
prime sets once you've gone past what's
involved move us beyond the line of
sight it's finding if you won't see many
more effect from that primary in that
profile
for a lot of activity i'll be one in
this five or six different ones to cover
all the momentum so the 15 basis of ya
have to get David Lee so it is a
clinical site so what what you want out
of a clinical application is yes or no
you don't want maybe this is what a
final is and maybe it doesn't I'm not
sure so in order to get that yes or no
the best way is going to be for your
pizza the same height you know any
better homozygous we've got a mutant you
want to know instantly if that's a
mutation and you want to in a 50-50 mix
yanna see half of those mutated
sequences going two incidents are giving
you a 50-percent prime you don't want
any background because that makes it
harder if he calls and you want to be
able to get the right answer costs
through a thousand bases thinking that
are basically what I'd be a measurement
so in a clinical situation where you've
got a person with two versions of each
gene the ability to pick heterozygous is
very important
and people have tried to get towards
this regulation regular piquant
situation in a number of ways in one of
those ways is manipulating the ends on
itself to make in corporations that I
more efficient like that incorporation
of the regular basis and so the items
that is on this and they discovered that
if if it is different introduce certain
mutation is in their hands on itself you
can reduce the discrimination against
the dies by large factors this helps to
regulate the sequence height but even
with that the profiles that I showed you
earlier clearly don't have regular
seekers I think apart
so how do how do we give you an artists
of the electorate now like from da Vinci
so first stage get the bedrock receive
second stage work out this place where
the peaks coming how far apart are they
third stage heterozygous baseball in
which positions have got the single base
which have got a mixture basis and from
different subspecies of evidene looking
since you've done that you're on an
assessment of equality how competent a
minor what I call this the right answer
am i under the sensual did that for like
one in ten chance of getting it right
what how well about them once you've got
the bases call you may I got your
sequence of a cgt whatever you need to
see how that differs from a reference
sequence or mutate this aside which
genotype is easily made this for their
front seven
so you do your little nothing to see
what exactly but if they have a library
of previously imagined sequences so
first thing import this hell out of here
now and most of the sequence has
produced a number of different variables
the each sequence first one is more came
straight out of the sensor the numbers
that can silence answer when you made it
that the diet Brussels from each and
each trace yes this is if these are the
keys second one is going to be adjusted
normalized because your laser powers not
only saying either I've got every time
temperatures going to vary the current
in that capillaries been about all of
these things so don't be a second one is
normalized to account for those
variations each die will emit light of
that over a spectrum of wavelengths so
if you get an anger see the magazine
crosstalk between the signals from those
teeth you need to make sure that you're
just for that so you make a matrix terms
and Loan sequence and you calculate how
much single country we remain you then
adjust your signal to compensate for
that when you press these strands
through a collective Aaron and some of
them fold up better than others inside
the jail if they fold up really well I
get a little bit less resistance to
being pulled through the public so you
might see me Pete supposed to be here
one move down here a little bit because
he went through the quick so you might
need to adjust your signals to account
for that and it depends what type do I
put me on the people unable to see on
and they might have a different folding
you might affect the speed through that
so you need to adjust for those things
and more people have been in the past is
that expanded sequence and I've just
seen what happened News afternoon
I don't know the other thing is it will
just give you a basic intensity
information to see whether you're a
pilot so what happens first is when it's
been normalized and just a little bit
yet this which is quite hard to read
have a good little bit more work with it
the way that maybe I at least do this is
that they divided the sequence of
inter-regional and each of these regions
they calculate how far cna move both
dignity so if you've got to see through
half positive but it to an alien that
particular sequence and you make an
adjustment each trace so that instead of
being unsynchronized
okay so so so I've got a and C and I
might have pays going a little bit clip
it so that they do this so that I had a
scene with the AIDS or with a season so
now if I've got a heterozygote I'm not
sure whether this goes with this one of
this one so what I do is I measure some
sequence and I make an adjustment and
say I think that I need to compensate
the page by this month yeah yeah so
using the calibration essentially and
that calibration is coming on central in
BF my too many machines so it's not
machine independent it's just chemistry
department I've use the same guys forget
the same as what you just pick one of
them in concert everything else against
that so if you if you could please your
concert
yeah so you just need to sign what if
you ship out all the fort and backwards
note there I'm so there are alternative
ways of doing that you know you can put
it to a function is it's with the
mobility of toleration in fact that you
know the the best-looking mobility is
imagine sitting can imagine then you've
got this one but most people are doing
that yet okay so you get a raw sequence
where the pits especially somewhere like
this they're not overlap particular well
if you doing their compensation then you
get a better alarm and even though it's
not the effect and that happens because
when you've got multiple corn or because
if they do interact with one another so
if you measure a solid sequence than any
major another epic is equal to still not
good enough 10 animated the sequence
animation again means that
so now you've got a relatively well
spaced set of peeps all different
heights so you want to do basically
first thing you have is going to decide
way then I put your limit of detection
so which which of these ones a real
signal than which ones are more then it
turns out that's really tough and that's
what limits your ability to detect the
mutation if you've got a high level of
background noise and you've got you four
basic leathers that's actually a bad
mutation but there's only a small amount
of that component in the assembled and
set it up you know we really hard
pressed to pull that out of a today
which is real much is this that just
noise well you've got to see how to
above that line then you start saying
these are heterozygous is definitely
mixed to hear so there are places in
that sequence this is a problem way
they're not sure so my logo or is that
will was it not real and one of the ways
you have helped that is by doing the
reverse sequence if that's not as it
won't appear here the sequencing in the
direction that would object it that's
one of the main problems what's your
limit of detection if I am quite few
things if one of them do humko very well
what happens on this about then why date
is not clean any further analysis I do
is not funny the whole school so that's
one of the problems it seems
okay so what I what you do is you say
which places are my confident I've got
right which ones are my not country got
right and you then make a score that
says for these bases do them exactly
what I want to see so piqued pretty eyes
conivent a reasonable size compared to
the peaks surrounding it there's not
very much background it's it's mobility
is you know it appeared where I want to
see it everything's good and so most of
these pits here for interesting you know
this this guy here fantasy question
about a good coffee this guy the
mobility is not right so it's more
difficult to make cool is that a while
Rick and CT have I got an extra base
inside a metal not so the competence is
going to be left there were these two
this case is the signal will so it
started for me to say basa g I'll have
to make some nice
so it turns out that if you do this
analysis vocalizing repeats you get a
good idea how good the sequences top
sequence no noise everything is easy all
the baseball's going to be right not
going to have a problem and I think
overall court in sport as you noise goes
up in quality score should go down and
it can tell you that it's having a
harder time I'm going to tell Thea so
that can allow you to keep your essays
up toward your ad says optimal there's
no word you're going to have to do
editing everything's automatic get down
to straightaway your seasoning is poor
portly it's hard to get the dancing and
if you've got a feedback mechanism you
can spot those things and sort them out
before it becomes a problem so I believe
I've got two sequences i need to score
for both of those now proptosis agree
and everything's good I've got an a in
both forward and reverse sequence
sequence read the Russians for this
everything's good everything's good
bakery and passed a good score this is
good this is harder because this is
dragged over from here for this little
separation between negative P so it
missed calls out call that right
conflict between two strands available
place the school has to be low
so when you do quality control we need
to decide what you main additive quality
control that's going to be and when we
do genotype is the HLA we separate that
I say the different excellence oh it
will will amplify one section of DNA
will sequence that and we'll do a
quality control on it for our next
section along four seasons that will do
a body control on it and if you do that
though multiple samples it's very clear
to see which ones can go through the
system without any checking and which
ones I've got a problem and this one is
clear that a problem you can see the
residence is not resolved it's completed
two footballs and it's been too
concentrated than the signal to run it
because so this isn't escape all the
right answer this is a really hard
alright hampson so but one of theories
want to be able to see when that happens
immediately and if the part that caused
scores across the exons individually
will see the exxon stream for this one
goes down on the very bloody goes either
so very need to see what in fact even
look at these three he's 125 that
reduces you have manual work both
because people have been looking at
these sequences by hand basin we go
through each placing both is this and it
is this amount next one is achieve is ok
next one so if you put out compare the
sequences work and he puts out a hundred
thousand bases us their global you don't
want to do
this is a known known gene that will not
novel them and you can just push that
analysis building / and if you've got if
your essays probably burns too much
you'll get a high score every time and
you won't get mistakes and you won't get
missed calls in there into that appeared
on treatment if one in fact is business
high-quality the balance as promised and
together we'll go to see very very
vintage is nothing called Ogando you
have to out more work do you want to see
this whole time
from design in the USA you need to know
what you're feelin additions are very
quickly I a few very concentration of
particular component of your we actually
if you want to clean up with ssl once
then your implication take anything away
that you use as a primary and reagents
you can see what the optimum
concentrations you use would be to give
you the best quality so if we keep
reducing the amount of x that we use to
clean up the quality we're going to get
out to a point where you have to do more
work so you know you can optimize
between the amount of work you have to
be eliminated interviews and it's always
been wishing to get more agent in
between that time the relative or you
have a missing some problems in epochs
who they have this didn't cost a thing
okay so once you've got you those coins
sort of ugly there's nowhere to put that
as your reference sequence way to this
web miss tienen que tinha gene page like
what we do is we measure the sequence
mr. coding sequence and the libraries
are just coding sequence so when you do
your alignment you chop off non-coding
sequence and fit that coding sequence
only against the library so I've
measured this sequence I gots followed
with on both sides of this goes into the
introns which is a non personally I
don't analyze that I chop it up I decide
what that sonic has it fits its most
consistent with so once I've been that
agreement along with something I HIV you
don't have that same situation it's
sickness straight through a natural line
holding little bit hard
it's another line that even with a clean
sharp object will happen if against the
reference I have a deletion there's some
bases missing in my seat things just
being my lymph nodes will say although
myself others because that sequence over
down and get the alignment sorted out so
we put a deletion against wrapping
something here now that's fine for
on-site signals no problem well happen
if I've got two different genes in that
provide tools together one's a me tender
variation without the cold watermelon
corners with some guys are doing that
separately they'll do the deletion one
separate to the insertion so my combined
sequence is now got mixed basis a lot of
positions and it's also got as part of
the sequence where their base is missing
in one but not the other so advocated
for that as well but the worse situation
is when i get few species in the same
cast to you one color deletion and one
doesn't want the basis shift up a little
bit here either one they don't now or
what i get is use them as a pepper
targets and have our full alcohol so
that's tough and in this situation these
are all current constant height and you
can't hold us like this come from stand
one was fun to about this spray heart
say that
so that's if it doesn't that's the
second problem it seems so what we're
doing it Rachel a bill matching against
the library the library may have a
certain sequence and they may not be 40
measured your sample comes in here so
you can you can say for a particular
allele how many bases it was fully
compatible with and how many didn't get
much again now I've got Hep azygous I've
got to contributing species I can say
how many of those faces in my son for
matched against both references between
two references i can say how many will
not sin against one reference and how
many will run much it's slightly complex
because i don't know the sequence the
Assad i gotta pass the test is still
compatible my biscuits and opponents of
an s isn't it the place is cheap but i'm
not sure what about right or wrong so i
can't call in this much
hla the library is so comprehensive for
the for the consequence in that we're
doing that it's incredibly rather you
wouldn't get zero miss Matson know the
answer and if you did get a nonzero
mismatch is submitted to the database
and they introduced that as a knob
Willie you have to get you have to
separate those two basically and say
this is novel Moby Cena false in the
balance of Education
you can parking spot back
Phase IV is completely off the ball
because you can get up and have any bags
so if you see a novel if you see another
polymorphism is no surprise there's a
skeleton yeah yeah there are skeletons
that yeah so you've got the skeletal
structure of it but you could imagine a
pond water nymph and everywhere part of
it whether you when people study a tape
of it how they do it they make a clone
and they are mine up clone and they fit
in this structure they did the data
actually is that quote alright so what
are you sequencing your sequence in that
quote what about everything else you've
selectively decided which hospital
you're going to see in 20 not gonna see
until you give is mixtures and when you
do the mixed is how do you know what
came from wherever just so it's great if
you get alleles out
yep
absolutely Chuck feedback
and I'll show you like it
okay so sorry observe the sequence from
samples got to two different stranded
DNA and that sequence comes out the
first one is an A and C together except
one to see that under 10,000 we've got
an energy together how do I know which
goes with which is the first a go with
us that the second deed is the first day
over the second date from that sequence
there to these thing that color either
there's no way I can know that so if
these are both novel wheels I don't know
the cities of either of those alleles I
only know that there are two possible
combinations and if there's more family
deity's than that's and garbage mention
so you can get a siege problem if you
want to work out what their parents
sequences are for these things so this
is the third problem of sequencing of a
mixture I going to tell what goes with
what and from that sequence i discard
yes okay Nate obviously Qin see if you
like do not have a couple bases
okay so how can I introduce feedback
into that system so that I can get back
to the I can use the fact that I've not
this in the first time I've ever made it
an HIV sequence again okay so I I've got
a list of alleles I know what they were
can I make mine artists don't improve my
analysis because I know that then I've
got to find ones that ok one gutsy one
of them got a really bad mobility shift
so I missed its yeah the g out of that
second is done and it looks quite good
so it's called at sea but I know that
the most compatible set of alleles with
that particular combination actually
that are made a demon team will make
more sense so I put I've mentioned back
in the baseball say there's one of these
fans agree with what I expected oh yeah
one of the sound is agreeable I expect
the other one's got a slight problem
because the mobility she have their
flaws to go back and make my consent is
different and that's that's the feedback
from their knowledge of ileal sequence
but you've got our peers phones to do
that because really you want to be had
some dispute between stones in order to
get back to their cells called city
so that's one way I can easily but again
improvement in the fitting it turns out
if you do that because a comment bubble
will be annoys peak Soviet the feet
that's nice and I don't want to be in
one span and it will be a not a severe
in the sense that it comes from
something other than that DNA that
you're making so that will be an
artifact the sequence but you'll start
out as a point all because seifert you
don't want to miss a formal so you
always want to tell somebody there may
be one here have a look at it blog for
missing it out ok so let Valentin very
corner if you go back and you know what
the parent the little sequences are what
is between to lie to be anything about
mall are doing are cut so maybe it makes
more sense many changes for so I'm
wondering when it does change if it
always brags that quarterback a 20
a better way to use feedback is to
acknowledge the fact that when you do an
HIV sequence will give your for a
particular region of HIV this isn't the
first moment and HIV sequence it may be
the 10,000th departments running but the
current methods of analysis say is it
the first time we've done this hey this
is a new sequence let's check it out so
there's no people are just not using the
huge few plants of data that are
available to us and that's probably a
mistake so one of the first things in
you see if you go in a sequencing
allowed me sit down and how to do
editing for like more than about 20
minutes it's really not very interesting
and the other thing is there to get like
this through sequences here from
different individuals and they've got
the same allele for the same sequence of
bases three different ones you can see
here is pan of intense trees it's
exactly the same at the time it's not
it's not changing this patient I am this
did you find this is perfect in sp these
two ways are higher natal is that is the
same every time if you do that
sequencing reaction thousand times
you'll see the same thing happen with
the other part so it makes sense to say
wait a minute I'm going to slap on well
let's let's do something about
and if you scaled in fences so I do one
reaction but a little bit bein out the
signal is weak do it again next week got
more den out the cinema stronger I need
to normalize for that bus go all the
sequences to take account of that and
it's very clear that the intensity
pattern is incredibly lucrative or from
one sequence to the next so what happens
when I use that I go from the data it
looks quite difficult to interpret the
date that looks a little bit easier to
interpret so have I got a 50-50 mixture
now it's incredibly easy for me to see
which one's of these contain
polymorphisms I don't just hope this
lose I going to scan you can see from
this when i leave intensity from this
one so I've not got one data point now
I've got to take points I know that if I
see a point more soon I have to reduce
intensity of seven feet so now I've got
two places I can get that data from sort
of one and I also find that is a very
regular there's no problem and I then
find what the second base is in any
situation
so now now go and automatically analyze
that it's going to be hard for me to
make a mistake as opposed to the
previous one might be quite easy for
some of those such a diverse positions
could be respectful in this court
I things you know
so there's a huge benefit in terms of
ability to automate sequencing if you
use the fact that you've done this a lot
I've before filippini data so what's the
significance problem one right how do i
distinguish between background and
signal this is quite small this is
blended if i do the adjustment this has
gone down as it's gone outfits clear
this is a retrovirus position no problem
at all i can pull up correctly every
time same thing here putting my maps not
so great in that position because
they're blending their stilts not bad
next thing is it turns out not very
clearly almost advice
turns out that you can actually quantify
these things so this is not just a
mixture of sequence then adding the pc
allison and mix this combined them
together got a sample on you took two
alleles mix them up and then peace the
oven so you get a eighty twenty percent
mixture UPC order goes through the whole
pcr publication stages goes to the
sequencing reaction all of those
chemical steps all those thousands and
millions and huge numbers of
interactions turns out that goes all the
way to the scene gets to the end the
signal intensity is proportional to what
you first fall in there so she got
twenty percent of them needs and
population that people it's going to be
twenty percent of what it would be a
fall under the Sun next week and that's
incredibly useful incredibly important
because if you've got his ins
progression or something like that if
you want to know how that leach is going
is it getting going up with populations
were going down in population he gives
somebody a vaccine what's it doing for
that population he treating somebody
with a particular drug is that
suppressing this mutation or is it
enhanced so now you can look at that you
can go back and see what effects that's
hunting on the natural dynamic effect of
the population of meetings enough
situation these guys Pearson Specter
this one
very grateful to them to help you this
is fairly early dating we haven't been
doing this and very long but it it seems
to be very negative on break using that
conclusion ok back to that
problem 2 so we've got probably one is
the noise over there problems who is
this kind of messy thing here where you
currently see what's going on Rosie but
I happens when we apply the previous the
feedback to this system here we know
what these people are supposed to be
that is quite clear which face comes
from would stand in that case you go one
stone that's the minor component one
standard two major component and we're
there to overlap you've had the bases
that are a hundred percent right there's
a like this some stuff is going to need
fixing what its blending in a have to do
some adjustments to things like that
again how to do these adjustments
because you know when you modify one
basic does have an effect on the next
three or four now to take more lessons
into account so it's only a little bit
refinement that's straight away I can
see what season still have got that I
can make computer told me what two
sequences are taught that I can make
them you'd tell me how that's affecting
affect how that's been affected how many
deletions I've got in one speech of the
etc and not the actual sequence both of
those species are so that's a quite big
step in in terms of analysis of mixed
use examples so you can get back to
directly the components of that system
provided you thought you know she had a
50-50 mix you can get in trouble again
so it's actually foremost a bit
unbalanced mixture
so what happens with this ambiguity
where I've got and several mrs. get a
sale this widens and what did I know how
I know which goes with which because
this T going with the aid of the T going
to see and this is slightly lower in
both cases but it's a bit close I'm not
sure which goes together okay brighter
than had a 50-50 mixture is very easy
ones go together and pull that apart so
now I got instead of a head like a
sequence but I don't know welcome to la
by two independent and right sequences
and I know what both of both of the
alleles are all fully statement
so what can I do now that I've got that
sorted out I can use sequencing fat but
any like a magnet high three because I
don't have to do manual work and I
opened up out with clean machines comes
out the sequences a week and those
sequences can down eyes on the road and
those who just can be taken up in places
law but then i'll buy number basis for
that huge number of people needing to
support it you know if I'm doing a non
clinical research that customers problem
ended with outdated by hand at all other
and because I've got QC the machine will
tell me when I do have a problem or not
do me to look at it so it'll clear
everything that goes through the system
and looks good that it will tell you
what you need to look at the militants
about so the amount of Labor involving
this is greatly reduced and this makes
it more suitable for a very high
throughput assistant the employment
issue 1 in 50 mph isn't even sequencing
you can run those sequences much quicker
than a tentative base or 800 base we
actually just 110 basis of it take you
that's less fun so many achievements
have become did platform in vc minus
type 1 newton screaming as well
when it be a quantitation Washington you
can have a look at you have a look at
Sur a patient with a leukemia and that
the communication polymorphism into that
immune system team we can see that one
authors and how much so we can see I
expect by treatment you can see if
there's relapse and we can do all that
very quickly in quantitatively so we're
able to detect relapse I can't afford
their symptoms when you do the
transplant again with a unrelated donor
you'll get possibility of climbers and
you can affect on that second type of a
little medicine is coming that very
early meeting point paper hey you can
look at HIV dynamically because he has
how simple they are evolving dynamically
over time we take patients but on very
one and take it to it's like you can see
what's happening with distribution of
species in that person and you can see
how your treatments linking for that
Katie you can do you can be a noble
point Morton's for the ability to detect
so what we do we're able to detect with
greater accuracy the presence or absence
of pointillism and piercings are fast so
you can get through a lot of sequences
in very short time beginning 5,000
reactions or we could analyze that or
1000 base sequence from a thousand
seconds instead of taking heart mad with
their by hand if algorithms are very
very fast and great directed towards
library based typing so you'll probably
know quite a lot about what is it is the
one for you so so you can skip a lot of
steps in your alignment if you do it
very quickly you know it personally
everything is together in the soft liner
so you get you a lot and sampling level
for the left they're going to have a bit
phenotyping all of us left all in one
place from with the addition of the peak
analysis you can move into new
applications you can automate that it
and you can do better quantitation and
we've got a software and a lot of April
a liability if not like these people
Frank shanira because the other heads of
endocrinology but so is my brother and
he worked over for either Simon and put
a lot of lantar be both it all
from those guys Rebecca and Lisa front
of light on the front line using it to
going back to mine is to make it better
at set forward places in those guys and
everyone else used in the sequence of
our plates it
over
yep
people are really good very good a look
at tons every that it's saying this is
an artifact this is a sequence of
strikethrough and they looked at it on
the time front end just no doubt of
field and they're a part of the thing
again the software is catching up
cooling and making it into an algorithm
so there's going yeah that so you
basically put out for these Titans you
know given a type of honor the method
you'll know what they're getting
something should I think they can
imagine thanks gran coupe these guys
have been allowed for wallets very good
software is it I the size of that other
people were argument and that yeah I
often half the party was the people even
last visit the mistress is upright the
way it works come from and it hasn't
been that good in fact
other people software I mean ours is
going to obviously three progression you
know first glance the journey doesn't go
oh that's right answer very light so you
notes it's above itself and you know you
we've got a dataset that comes with it
to your place from the particular
machine with a pity or chemistry
everything is going to be optimized
towards that because if you do something
different with it you know you can after
perhaps in condemning some cases it's
it's surprising how robust is if you
transfer platform now if you put in a
different machine who is a different
polymer to put that down a tree it's
it's surprising how incredibly robust
these indigo and it's person as a
testament to the fact these is revolved
know the ones that weren't robust just
didn't make it
we're probably on a single season two
mounting reverse probably something like
taking mistake one in five hundred and
it's normally associated with the
presence of noise and some you know
similar time we've got a peek through
that and there it'll look like the real
thing there's no way you can cause on
the real thing but it was just something
else in there in that tube or in their
people and there's you know what can you
do about that
if a sequencing is a sufficient court
when you can make this type
basically HIV is different again no you
must all right nation-state great timing
because you cannot have low level from
population you're going to get the right
major speaking or you don't know what it
sequence is you know there's no gold
standard is no part of we've got the
sequence here now to test the software
against the known sequence because there
isn't one I'm for everybody there is in
sequins in our view because sequencing
is the end product of the compensating
step you've isolated that person's that
DNA from that person's blood have you
isolated everything that is in there
you'll amplified various parts of that
have the amp vitals we change it were in
there probably not because your climbers
who could have going on for some things
much better than others so that guy's a
huge source of you have mr. mutations
right there then you do your sequencing
you know your efficiency but personally
think my problem too undetectable so
they've met across and walk so right all
the way to get then you know you you're
not going to get rely on to HIV
yes and you know an HIV sequence
everyone might be slightly different
pretty much so you what you're going to
detect if you're going to get the fact
of the trend now which ones are
surviving the best and those are going
to be the most important than in any
case and no the other ones it was going
to run or I could go at this and see if
it works but perhaps not so important so
what way looking forward you look at the
one for the survivors and you want to
know why but I
that's correct yeah because you you
amplify what you expect so this time I
believe that it's hard to get out of the
only do I try and stack to the sequence
you say will start through a little bit
we're making department isn't it another
location we'll see what what that brings
about in terms of polymorphism in the
last prime of cycling making the comment
you know it to do you have that it's
always kind of bootstrapping upon those
things and you just you can't you don't
get it for that you've got you will have
to do is get the best answer for that
person in terms of one of the best
fitted HIV sequences for that missing
there are these features of the sequence
that won't have that sequence to be best
suited for that individual and the other
thing is when you're doing a I'll
write you you're splitting this thing up
into fragments how do you know that each
of those fragments come from the same
one so it's a tough problem last always
says it cut off the ends and it fits
them together so it will make the
consensus out of several different one
and it was the line them all together
because it warm only did we turn your
curtains other than I one
self i discouraged often it is half
this is a piece one so if you get your
message from Microsoft saying please
contact microsoft in consider yourself
this is bitter
this is only we're not have things in
heavy development associated with it
stop reading on browsing do the whole
directly to us won't be back in there
so that 10,000 citizens
just places them so you know you've got
this continuous length of DNA projets
not a year it just places that in the
correct spot for that stun PLA and then
it looks to find out where that stops
matching probably after that it'll it'll
cut it off the sequence now is turn off
anyway you've got everything blending
together and sore too long there's
probably some insertion or deletion of
about it it's just not getting enough
handle left I've donated to make up
probably
and so is it yeah that's the end of that
whole sequence anyway
yeah yeah it's completely controlled so
when you've got to have and a PCR when
you're being an amplification what you
do is you divide you've devised to
primal one problems got a specific
sequence that fits into the whole
sequence the other one for the nurses
can see them and if you design those
right I'll just drugs the spot in there
and it's at the same place every time
and everybody said everyone so you gotta
save me so it's completely controllable
and you know if I use these primers
always start here and there
and maximum read length so machine is
kind of eight hundred odd basis but you
know you could consider going longer
than that if you only wanted to do
single standard sequence you know then
you can get out 1500 if you're seeking
sympathy actions and you didn't want to
have over up but mostly will do both
directions to try and get confirmation
and improve the signal to knowledge
party in protea is a friendly and this
summer reading you got to let me not be
reckless sequence not very much
polymorphism elephant this is set up to
be going on 20 mismatches against
reference here so out of what 400 500
basis that's pretty regular sequence
he builds up its mother over time the
first time and does something and
doesn't have an idea so as you keep
sequencing people can building at the
map which is why the restaurant rather
than inflation and it won't always have
information for positions if you've got
mobile portal so you don't know what
that was supposed to be infinite
intensity so you'll see some variation
and privacy even want to spy to get a
grip on what's going on
that they come along to judgments on
plans and go in these coins one of the
best places for pond why the variability
is the smallest and then sometimes
you'll get a sample of what half of our
farmers in your appetizer unless we get
really really tricky for your gap
crunchy species on with Aboriginal
without managed to prevent so we can
probably cause a problem
try Epsom Olympic under that cover a
real party
how is the
so at the moment all about information
is not very well consolidated in is in
various places in various databases and
one of the main problems that needs to
tackle is putting all of this together
to get proper feedback you know which
primers and provide the best which ones
pail of water they fail which ones are
the best ones to use in case of an
update the software should say this is
failed because he probably got both
motors in here and we found the passive
this time as well well for these guys
and it should tell you that but if you
know those people in the lab they're
doing that by ham of the moment it takes
longer to do those things than it does
to do any of the five experiment
so did this this is a piece of the
puzzle you again their electric bill
analysis of the piece of puzzle I
thought out comes this huge problem with
what is the what are all these species
mean well you know what what does it
mean in terms of the structure of the
envelope has this effective interaction
with a chelating all of those things
vinopolis you need to make it easy you
need to make mistake out to the people
doing that easily this is something we
don't have a moment this is steps to
suffer this this needs to be fitted
pattern
absolutely after
so all of them they're all daddy's going
to the database and it you know you need
to get up these feedback steps now
there's a better credit so you've been
analysis you find a new voice e84 this
position for this type of age late right
you've measured wonder you never saw
back to what we do is go straight back
to baton and was there any evidence
because this about a sport you know that
it gets called less than twenty percent
certainty can I try pullin up
immediately there was there a t-bone
look I faculty that it shipped in a good
so all of those things innovate those
who dat chemicals and then that's
wireless nice integration to further
this is it all depends are these
sequences in different people
this is the rock paragraph this
yeah yeah yeah so this is a quality
control for the that I have to thank you
for the single strand this is the
consensus we've only got once done here
is the same but it consensus this this
is like school in North 50th and
sensitive the North 150 or two and I
refuse 10-2 government had a chance to
get it right and it got 134th
understanding that did a reverse one
this is from the same as that but when
i'm going to got one big pointy nominal
can either be under the side certain
that this is not more I did it the other
way maybe it'd be much better for this
sequence it makes no difference if I'd
had ceased and it would make difference
so in this case it's more complicated
authorities found one I agree you can
school and they don't agree there were
school this is kind of my tests rated
for the worst yeah
yeah so that each strand separates got a
score than the Sun together got another
consensus is no don't
there's more contests that this is the
worst day to I have you know we're
trying to make it go
and that's kind of messy
wasn't for Israel AmeriCorps terrific
with the basic
with an actual TV
this is actual sequence
this is the reference sequence so this
is a combination of all the gnomon oils
to Gary what this is a reference this is
a consensus report in Reverse this is
called reverse
decision as the yellow
decisions for individual
these things are
oh yeah that's only a line at the point
x then borrowed everything else the visa
fixed length lesser than the secret
didn't pick length so they're like
they're only aligned on that on that
spot where the bar is you can't say on
exit it's pale
yeah it displays any displayed any way
around quite and Dominic like the
sequence and basically
that you can do what you want but it's
gone of one is one is time you know what
is simple kind of like you know making
everything with fit 16 pixels or
whatever you know can't we bother to do
that is it essential for the programmer
in what we're trying to do at the end of
day stop you from opening these things
so in a help and look at it's probably
you know I can compensate I can make all
the people it's not the same work that
it's there are other things like
mobility ships you know if I just peed
works of his 17 pixels and that's one to
be 30 pixels and is one of the middle
it's going to get kind of distorted and
that's I be some kind of smooth and
clean between those two 13 and 17 and
closely like that so I just it's just
not going to prioritise I other than it
can become
you can see that these about course the
right they've got red ones a good court
you want mrs. inez
I think I better start to be very very
very sensitive to be taking to the money
is it son this is a kind of worth in
progress 1 i'm trying to do things like
and they're chopping off my birth it's
making sure that point infection run
baseball economy so it's kind of under
variation at the moment this version
also accident it's not yet this
untrained
so that's before
not surface
the other thing is that when you if I
analyzed two different settings in
chemistry I'll get contamination of my
height map so if I use one type of
diamond ease into the pipe dial
variations and easy to work one of it by
recognitions and corner recognitions out
make it robust Chemical you
absolutement when it snows
you
what you're
that's good we can smile just a fan
you
I can sometimes galley of that it needs
refinement what you know combining this
together and needs to be more answers
about how to strip the defective Megan
places to you but for that pic run like
to get out but I couldn't
hey
No
but you know I know the way to do it
just a matter of you know how much time
can ask xfinity TV a coating to get that
idea into the this implementation that
there will be systemic problems a lot of
things you know so what will happen is
it it will start doing some sequences
first have sequence i'll show you
develop depending on the mixture ratio
depending on level that noise so you'll
get some adverse so you just keep
claiming the data
I'm sure people fight over it I mean
that's that beta silence tape so you
know I mean I guess he's everyone we've
got coming back to anyone it was anybody
else uncover what could for mixtures
like that you know it won't be my leg
got prone
in public rotated is that you know every
single sequence has been negative on
that illnesses you know what was it what
the laser was doing at that time
all right okay with you if I fall asleep
even slap
you